[Música]
boa noite a todas ea todos
dizer que é uma satisfação imensa estar
aqui e tentar transmitir alguma coisa
que ao longo desses meus 54 anos de vida
destes 32 já dedicados à educação a
parte de ensino superior
se eu considerar mais a graduação são 37
então realmente a maior parte da minha
vida estive à frente da educação a
educação uma coisa que me apaixonou e à
minha família
incrivelmente ao longo de muitos anos
sempre se preocupou muito em educação
o meu bisavô no início do século e
transato era engenheiro já quando que
mínimo da população brasileira tinha
acesso ao ensino superior
meu bisavô com o engenheiro foi
responsável pela construção da estrada
de ferro que ligava porto alegre até à
fronteira com a argentina teve oito
filhos e desses oito filhos todos
naquela época foram para ensino superior
e portanto a educação sempre presente na
vida deles sendo meu avô
o filho mais novo irmãos médicos
advogados na águ advogado também dele
irmãs professoras pedagogas sempre
ligadas à educação quando também o
brasil no início do século passado nada
apresentava com relação à educação
superior
eu vou ter três filhos dentre os quais o
meu pai médico também de um engenheiro
uma tia professora sempre a educação nos
acompanhando a vida toda eu meu irmão e
meu médico e um advogado procurador
federal mas sempre com a vocação para o
ensino
infelizmente nem vejo hoje realizado que
desde os meus filhos meus três filhos
a vitória entre o julho todos já com o
ensino superior então eu digo que educar
sempre é uma missão que me acompanha a
mim durante toda praticamente a minha
vida e acompanha minha família
demonstrando a importância
do conhecimento e nós nos formarmos aí
pensando pensando do que eu vou falar
sobre esta missão de educar sempre como
foi minha trajetória baseada em que o
que eu posso contribuir para um público
tão jovem tão cheio de vontade de
conhecer saber de evoluir de ter alguma
coisa enfim o que eu vou falar e eu
pensei e refletir ao longo da minha vida
e pensei em dez palavras eu tenho 18
minutos no máximo pra falar sobre ações
e educam ações de educar sempre um
advérbio fortíssimo né
sempre todo dia todo momento para todos
e eu pensei o que falar
como cheguei aonde cheguei hoje estou à
frente de uma instituição de ensino aqui
em santa maria a faculdade de direito de
santa maria hoje eu sou diretor geral
foi professor da universidade federal de
santa maria foi procurador federal o
advogado ao longo de muitos anos e
quando cheguei isso talvez sirva um
pouquinho pra que vocês possam enfim
nessa trajetória que vocês buscam
kentaro talvez isso que eu digo pra
vocês
usar essas palavras calma pessoal
calma muita calma
eu fui o cara mais nervosinhos do mundo
querendo que tudo ocorresse
imediatamente eu vejo meus filhos vai
porque que não ocorreu ainda ocorre
pessoal
4º esta primeira palavra e eu uso esse
mantra que o meu velho pai sempre metido
calma calma eduardo e hoje ainda muito
mais nem com essas novas tecnologias da
informação é tudo tão rápido
muitas vezes recebe ainda usa e meio
talvez nem 11 mais mas sei lá uma
mensagem no hati zap sei lá o quê é tão
mais rápido e nós ficamos na ansiedade
louca de tentar resolver aquilo
instantaneamente louco que as coisas
aconteçam instantaneamente
calma calma pessoal calma porque as
coisas irão acontecer
naturalmente no seu momento certo
calma não quer dizer simplesmente ficar
no ostracismo
calma não é isso é calma é raciocinar
para que as coisas ocorram naturalmente
conforme o curso natural da vida
mas não basta só calma é preciso método
pessoal
a ausência absoluta de metro na condução
de qualquer ação realmente ela nos leva
a um desperdício de energia e muitas
vezes insucesso nas nossas realizações
calma junto com o método é eu vejo as
pessoas muitas vezes querendo planos
mirabolantes coisas mirabolantes mas com
zero de planejamento 0 enfim de método
na condução das suas acções método de
planejar método é realmente fazer as
suas coisas com calma cada uma as suas
no seu devido momento
então eu sempre digo que a minha vida
foi pautada no método mas não aquele
método que cega não há forma pela forma
o método que permite planejar planejar
as ações planejar a sua o seu
comportamento de vida não sendo
simplesmente um pragmático mas um método
porque as coisas aconteçam
verdadeiramente como tem que ser
mas também não basta só ter meta da
minha vida não foi só com calma ou com
método ela precisa muita iniciativa
pessoal
não podemos ser meros espectadores na
nossa vida na condução das suas acções
na condução da educação
nós temos que ter iniciativa nós temos
que ter aquilo que se diz proatividade e
eu vejo realmente que este é indicador
que a nossa juventude hoje eu pelo menos
tenho convivido ao longo de anos com
jovens especialmente jovens que entram
no ensino superior
eu realmente entendo que a iniciativa
hoje é muito
maior do que era talvez o que ocorre é
que falte calma e falte método mas a
iniciativa é fundamental mas também não
adianta só essa iniciativa pessoal é
preciso ter muita persistência em tudo
na vida
eu sempre digo que as pessoas hoje têm
aquele fogo de palha né muita iniciativa
vamos fazer isso essa idéia que ela
enfim até pode entrar a gente planejar e
eu estou colocando estas palavras essas
ações talvez numa ordem cronológica que
permita eu ter calma ter método ter
iniciativa
mas não basta só iniciativa é preciso
persistência
eu digo especificamente na minha
actividade profissional e hoje eu posso
dizer que não vou dizer
sucesso absoluto mas eu vejo que eu sou
realizado no que faço
já formei inúmeros jovens no ensino
superior a instituição que eu estou à
frente realmente é uma instituição
inovadora é uma instituição enfim que
têm metodologias novas que usa as novas
tecnologias que trabalha muito com
extensão que trabalha muito com pesquisa
que tem núcleos específicos que trata de
meio ambiente segurança cidadã tem 11
mil nec um lucro que trata da web
cidadania temos um núcleo de
empreendedorismo e prática profissional
enfim temos um núcleo de direito
internacional
eu sou realizado mas isto graças a muita
persistência
então se vale a calma se vale o método
se vale a iniciativa vale a persistência
mas sobretudo nós somos de pessoas
pessoas nos ajudem e aqui eu fiquei
muito feliz porque eu vi o gerônimo via
natália virgin rafinha falando e vi que
falamos exatamente de pessoas e talvez
não combinamos nada mas realmente vejo
que as pessoas são fundamental
eu sempre digo é muito bacana toda uma
tecnologia é muito lindo uma bela sala
de aula é muito lindo um projeto
pedagógico maravilhoso é muito lindo é
muito lindo mas se não tem pessoas que
façam isso acontecer as coisas não
funciona então se sirva um exemplo para
vocês na condução
vida e na minha condução de vida eu
sempre coloquei nas pessoas porque são
as pessoas que têm condição de fazer com
que aqueles sonhos se realizem que
aquelas idéias se realizem aquelas são
as pessoas que fazem a modificação não
são as pessoas a humanidade que leva à
humanidade para frente é fundamental
então eu digo que se ter calma é bom se
ter método é fundamental se ter
iniciativa é não ser ator é não ser de
espectadores em ator se ter persistência
importante mas se não tem as pessoas que
estão junto conosco para nos ajudar a
conduzir tudo isso de nada adianta
e aí tem se falado muito em experiência
eu sempre digo eu sempre tenho este
hábito e vejo que na condução destas
acções de educar sempre eu sou muito de
ouvir essas pessoas
a experiência destas pessoas
a decisão rápida ela muitas vezes pode
ser responsável
mas a decisão de morada também ela é
irresponsável muitas vezes então a
experiência dos mais velhos que já
passaram e há um ditado que diz que o
diabo sabe mais por ser velho do que por
ser diabo é verdade
a experiência experiência não é ver a
alegria experiência são pessoas que já
tiveram oportunidade muitas vezes de
experimentar coisas e que muitas vezes
deram certo não deram certo
então eu posso também transmitir a vocês
esta ideia é perfeito o método está
perfeita iniciativa da perfeita enfim a
persistência na condução eu tenho as
pessoas mas muitas vezes não escuto as
pessoas e principalmente escutar as
pessoas com experiência
a experiência é fundamental mas não só a
experiência pessoal
nós precisamos dos jovens nós precisamos
de inovação e eu sempre digo que a
inovação não pode dar as costas para
isso
ele em si mas ela tem que ouvir a
experiência então equação muitas vezes
difícil de trabalhar com pessoas
experientes e espesso e pessoas
inovadoras
talvez esta mescla esta mistura de
experiência com inovação pessoa porque
muitas vezes a inovação e é fundamental
para a condução os nossos destinos
ela é fundamental para a evolução desta
humanidade destas pessoas é fundamental
mas ela não pode ficar cega a
experiência ea experiência não pode ser
de tal forma retrógrada que não deu
oportunidade para que a inovação
prossiga por que a humanidade nós só
vamos evoluir e aqui educação é nossa
evolução intelectual é a nossa evolução
como pessoas é nossa evolução no mundo
porque algum significado deve haver a
nossa presença aqui então são situações
que devem estar de mãos dadas
isto eu trabalhei durante toda a minha
vida como professor como gestor de uma
instituição de ensino superior como
empresário que também o senhor porque é
uma instituição privada que não tem uma
suspensão o governamental enfim não têm
uma ordem religiosa ou é condicional é
uma empresa também em mesclar talvez
esta é a parte acadêmica educacional de
inovação de experiência de método de
calma na condução com a parte acadêmica
talvez seja o maior desafio que possa se
ter mas isso me deixa tranqüilo porque
todas essas palavras elas se resume no
conhecimento é pra isso nós estamos aqui
para acumular conhecimentos e esses
conhecimentos nós efetivamente
transmitirmos as gerações futuras
eu sempre digo am que o lindo
maravilhoso da educação ou do ensino da
pesquisa e da extensão
se faça realmente esta possibilidade de
levar às pessoas o conhecimento é o
trabalho mais prazeroso que possa se ter
é ter um empreendimento evidentemente
tem finalidade lucrativa com alguma
coisa que dê prazer que possa realmente
deixar um legado para essas pessoas é um
produto e eu não gosto de usar esse nome
mas é um produto diferente é um produto
intrínseco que este usuário vai ter
diferente de um objeto que alguém
adquira que pode estragar pode enfim
ficar defasado o coisa enfim até para os
do direito né sofrer a infecção é perder
esta coisa para outra se diz
o conhecimento não o conhecimento bem
adquirido ele não sofre pressão de não
sofre a perda para outros porque ele é
um bem absorvido por vocês
pelo nosso usuário pelo nosso
destinatário e é este conhecimento me
deixa absolutamente satisfeito que se
conseguiu produzir algo negócio que
efetivamente tenha condição de dar ao
seu destinatário algo próprio algo
subjetivo e educação
é uma outra palavra e já estamos
chegando à nona falei que seriam dez
palavras a educação na verdade ela
representa todas essas outras palavras
que até agora que falamos comissão
comissão de vida a educação seria este
instrumento de levar o conhecimento as
pessoas levar a calma na condução das
suas acções
o método a iniciativa levará
persistência congregar as pessoas juntar
a experiência daqueles que já aprenderam
com aqueles que estão aprendendo estão
inovando
acreditar naqueles que estão inovando
mas não descuidar naqueles que têm
experiência e tudo isso somado nos faz
realmente acreditar que a educação é a
única forma existe da evolução da
humanidade
não há outro caminho a não ser a
educação não há outro caminho de se
procurar transformar as vidas pessoais
transformar as vidas daqueles que estão
ao nosso lado transformar a nossa
família transformar as nossas
comunidades mais próximas do vizinho de
porta até alguém que eu não sei que
muitas vezes com o conhecimento
transformador
eu estou realmente cumprindo minha
missão
mas eu queria dizer uma coisa pra vocês
para encerrar uma décima palavra é muito
bom ser empreendedor é muito bom
maravilhoso ser um empreendedor que faz
coisas enfim lhe agradam que trazem
retorno é muito bom ganhar dinheiro
porque é bom ou ruim infelizmente eu não
sei se a maravilha a praga da humanidade
mas enfim as pessoas precisam muitas
vezes quando eu digo dinheiro não digo
dinheiro o é tão antigo renda porque os
negócios precisam funcionar os negócios
precisam enfim se pagar é preciso que
têm os equipamentos e prestei a luz
enfim
infelizmente ou felizmente todo mundo
quer e acredita que estão já estejam
aqui ouvindo ações que educam ações
enfim que possam ajudá-los a transformar
a sua vida ações enfim que possam
permitir que vocês cresçam que você se
transforma em que vocês modifiquem mas
tudo isso pessoal eu posso afirmar para
vocês não teria razão nenhuma de ser se
não houver felicidade no que a gente faz
porque é o final e ao cabo das nossas
existências nesta vida a felicidade ao
final que importa a felicidade de ouvir
crianças tocando violino aqui em cima a
felicidade saber que alguém modificou
cresceu o que eu pude ajudar algum o a
felicidade pessoal nós os que estão com
a gente
os nossos filhos a felicidade estão bem
porque isso é o final é o carro que
importa de tudo porque de nada adianta
toda calma todo o método da iniciativa
toda a persistência todas as pessoas
se não tivermos a felicidade
espero que possa ter contribuído por
mínimo que fosse com essas palavras para
vocês porque isso eu tenho certeza
hoje me deixou imensamente feliz de
estar aqui com vocês muito obrigado
[Música]